how's it going everybody this is a blitz
brawl like no other joining me here is
super grandmaster Wesley so and when we
say super grandmaster we're not kidding
Wesley is uh I believe top 15 in the
world right now currently number 12
perhaps so it's fair to say he's going
to bring his a-game
why exactly I thought this was a
challenge worthy of recording so that
everybody on YouTube and chess comm can
see me get my proverbial bleep handed to
my proverbial bleep but I don't know you
know I'm not really big on thinking
ahead most of the time so right now we
have a closest iliyan and we're going to
try to learn something about these games
as we go with this early Bishop to b5
reaches the structure that leaves
something to be desired for black on the
queenside he has ideas like Queen h4 and
Knight g5 and sort of typical attacking
ideas have to be careful about east 6
because then he'll play e5 which breaks
up the double pawns here so what exactly
should the right plan be I'd like to get
c4 at some point to have to perhaps on
double the pawns and and I I know that
he'll likely play b3 soon because his
Queen defends the knight so there's no
tactics here so so I'm not exactly sure
what the what the proper plan is I'm
going to play a move that's sort of
random but potentially annoying a little
bit of a sore throat I've been fighting
this week so my voice is a little bit
off now he's going to play b3 exactly
precisely and it's not it's not a very
fun position for me on a positional
level I even want to play want to play
c4 at some point just to sack the pod so
I can create counter play c4 and then c5
especially if I can get the rook to be 2
this will be
how I play I need to speed up obviously
I'm playing one of the fastest best
calculators in the world I don't expect
to really win more than I don't know
that I expect to win any games honestly
but this is going to be fun and so this
is a this is a live session special here
and we will see what Grand Master's of
this calibre all about he takes with the
deep on anticipating my rook would come
to be to the e4 pawn here is now
potentially a week that's one of the
points I'd like to hope for but the
queen is looking more and more awkward
isn't she yeah she really is it's not
looking too pretty for her if I play c5
to open up the diagonals then the night
gets d5 I'm going to try to bring the
Queen back slowly I do have the bishop
pair and this is a 3-2 game we are
playing at 3-2 time control which is the
newest most awesomest time control added
to chess comm that's three minutes with
a two-second increment it's the world
feed a blitz time control the standard
time control so let's see he wants a
five this really does not feel great
right now it certainly does not feel
great hmm I'd like to get my queen over
to g4 if I took the Queens off the board
it actually have pretty decent chances
in the endgame with the bishop hair and
flexible pawn structure but but Queen d7
is met by e5 so I don't know I just I
have to play faster I'm going to play
faster and if this turns into a
slaughter of a game it turns into a
slaughter of a game and then we play
again don't we we roll the dice
that's what it's all about yeah he's
going to take it you know it's a shake
and bake it he's going to move that
Knight from F free and create some
damage on f6 I'm aware I'm aware of
exactly what you're trying to do to me
I was hoping that I had this move and
that you couldn't skewer my rooks right
away with Bishop before I know he wants
to maybe on the dark squares and he has
plenty of compensation but survive is
what I do I'm drinking
two bags of mint tea out of my honey
badger don't care a cup today that's
right let's say you know I'm bringing my
a-game not kiddin around when when you
get that honey badger cup going ah wait
a second do I have Queen h4 no I do not
there's nothing to it I blew it let's
move it baby we need to pick up the
speed
I'm not sure that exchange sack was
actually so great for him to be totally
honest ah here he comes with 94 I did
not see that coming
ouch owie owie owie
I play workout 5 which sort of defends
it because if Knight f6 I would take it
but then he has this move hmm
but I guess I have to take on it for huh
and now he's going to put the pony on f6
and it's not going to feel great it's
not over yet though it's blitz maybe I
can place c5 and put the bishop on b7
and get some diagonal action going
sometimes you got to work it on the
diagonal no diggity you know what I mean
your Bishop is like a ninja
stealthy finding attacking opportunities
rook to d4 wait no that wasn't so great
I take care he's going to give a little
double check little tickle little tickle
Ali
oh I could have played now I couldn't
yeah well that's a resigned times kids
that's when you lose your queen and you
throw it in against a player like this
but we're going to rematch it and do it
again we're gonna run it back like a
broken record all day long that hurt
he's taking his time you know he loves
the fans that Wesley you know he's a
he's a sucker for a compliment you know
he's adorable he's adorable that's
really the truth he is adorable
alright let's play d4 and let's bring
the pain this time let's see how he
handles the varus off I guess I deserve
what I get huh
happy to get on the board happy to not
be completely skunked in this this
session today
so let's do this we're playing a scotch
he knows about it we all know about I'm
going to play this line here
my favorite dough when it comes to blitz
ss SS and honor feed a the Olympian if
you're missing Olympia coverage you can
find it on chess com all kinds of great
hosts every morning in the Pacific
morning on the East Coast and early
afternoon if you're in Europe and if
you're in Russia I guess mid-afternoon
evening and if you're further east it's
probably closer to midnight but I'm not
a scientist I did stay at a Holiday Inn
Express last night that's all I got this
is a typical kind of transition it's a
tough it's a tough one to make if you
don't have it prepared because you're
giving up the bishop hair and you know
visually sort of weakening your
structure here but this is this is a
good for white because the point is the
C file is really important for putting
pressure on blacks weaknesses and you
know this is sort of typical I played
this way before I put the bishop on on
f2 I'm remembering the other rook to c1
and target target the c5 pawn we've seen
this before
Queen to d5 I can actually I can even
play something like Queen f3 and if take
stakes he takes on d3 it's just it's
just not ideal he's going to play h4 and
then bring the rook up to g6 and it's
not going to be super fun so I'm going
to make some I'm going to take some
prophylactic measures which is to get my
rook over to g1
yeah I don't really know I mean maybe
this is totally fine for black really I
haven't played it enough to just claim
that I know white is doing fine I guess
I'll stop this shenanigan I wasn't sure
that was the best because of moves like
that but I thought I was taking a five
and maybe getting c4 but okay he thinks
this is fine for him he thinks it is
fine for him indeed well I have a past a
pawn and his see pawns are terrible so
on a positional level we like white that
is fo sho
Bopha show interesting he backs up he
backs up buttercup I can play a six and
then get this check and go to a seven
it's kind of fun he'll probably castle
here avoiding as it checks yeah but now
now we have a seven and then we can
actually I don't know put a rook on a
one maybe I should have tried to keep
that pollen a six longer huh I didn't
realize how irritating that was for him
that I was uh keeping his Bishop out of
e7 so I might have been a mistake by me
but okay let's see if I can bring the
other rook over to be one and maybe sack
the exchange or something still just an
absolutely wild position I would love to
go sack the exchange I think I
I think I would love to go sack that
exchange let's do it huh who plays
Bishop c6 but does you realize that now
he can't move his rook off of the e1
square because I might have rook to b8
the main issue for me of course is this
irritatingly awkward and g2 pawn so I
play this move rook to b2 to guard it
and now I'm going to take h4 well
unfortunately Wesley's let me know that
the US team is ready for dinner
so last game against me right now last
game heartbreaking
Wesley's leaving us everybody we're back
to the lowly world of blitz against non
number 12 rated in the world players
such a shame maybe I can get this game
maybe I can get a win before he leave so
it's not like you know last game and
then he just beats me it's like thanks
buddy I'd like to target the h4 pawn it
feels like I should be getting something
more aggressive I can play Queen to b1
and then try to play you know rook to b8
and try to push the pawn home but I wish
there was a way really to target the c5
pawn so I think the more I think about
it it makes me realize that the knight
on on c4 is is now misplaced actually
and maybe he belongs on e4 now or even
f3 right because the targets have
changed and so this Knight is no longer
ideally placed on c4 c4 he's definitely
going to consider sacrificing the
exchange but I think I can handle that I
think I think I can handle that
situation the other move I might play
actually it's just Queen to f3 offer the
Queen trade right ok let's let's go
guard g2 then if he plays Bishop d7 I'll
play Queen f3 ah Ali Ali what do you say
Lane d'arnot man alright if I play
Knight to c4 I guess I'm still holding
on for dear life I would love if there
was something else like rook takes e5
2594 of the discovery wait if rook takes
c5 he takes I can take his rook if he if
he takes on g2 I take he takes the Queen
I take and the N I'm up a piece right so
I can do this took probably a little
more time than I really wanted to on
that but then I played this instinctive
tactic but I don't think it works take
on e - lets play 94 he'll play Queen a5
yeah we're going to have to take care
and I know the F pawn is not so much fun
but if he takes that way I thought I'd
have this check maybe well maybe that
was an immature and silly idea because
now he has this ah darn it darn it darn
it darn it
guess I can take here and then play
Bishop to g3
who
yeah but now I can play Bishop g3 and
then maybe rook have you recovered f2 ah
he wants a queen trade I get it but I
don't I don't want this I would love to
play Queen to c5 but no and play queen
e8 but then I'll play Queen to c5 a lot
of time here not a lot of time for
anybody though he's not he doesn't have
a lot of time either now I can play rook
F - AHA but now now I bring the Queen
back check the d5 bishop
you
okay please c6 button but now we go back
to d6 so hit the the pawn
gotta be something now right yeah baby
he's falling apart it's gonna be mate
and just like that I managed to get on
the board before the match was over well
I don't know I'm proud of myself okay
finally managed to win a game but not
not the best play from Wesley does last
this last game here let's lie in the
Scotch a little tricky but I think I
think I need to look more into this
right here because this whole h5 idea
where the Queen sits on d5 and normally
there's also this sort of aggressive
rook lift that's possible is another way
to black and play I think Robert has
actually played that way against me I
think it was has but okay I think he
lost his way when he started this sort
of Queen side plan with a5 and rook b8 I
think the black needs to be more
aggressive with the tying down White's
pieces here first castling isn't ideal
but okay you know what it was an epic
match a an epic day we learned something
from mostly Wesley beating me down but
we think the number 12 in the world soon
to be number 2 player under the US flag
changing his Federation so he will be
right behind the car Nakamura and Wesley
is a regular people he's played in death
matches before you can actually see him
playing in a death match in October
against a Cara Nakamura so it's us
number one and two we are so excited for
that match October fourth market down
chess calm TV coverage the highest rated
death match in the history of probably
anything that will ever happen again
with the number five in the world versus
the number 12 in the world player so
thank you everybody for watching thank
everybody watching everywhere all over
the world and we will see you around on
chess calm